why don't you give an overview of your
theory for those who are uninitiated a
broad Strokes
view well the ctmu is a theory of
everything there are two kinds of Theory
of Everything one of them is a physical
Theory usually it's related to a unified
field theory in some way which means the
forces of nature is supposed to be
unified into one General Force um but of
course that's only part of reality and
my theory is a theory of everything in
the metaphysical sense it actually has
to conform to certain logical criteria
which in philosophy and metaphysics
govern what a what a Theory of
Everything has to be so I like to
characterize it as the language that
reality speaks to itself about itself it
is a language a language is an algebraic
structure this is a particular kind of
language that reality actually uses to
communicate with itself and to make
decisions regarding how it models itself
which is another way to say how it
evolves right and it's uh it can be
modeled in in many ways you can actually
look at it as an operator algebra or as
a quantization a new kind of
quantization of
reality or reality self- simulation you
can look at it from from the perspective
of quantum mechanics as quantum metam
mechanics I believe you must have read
that paper or you mentioned having that
or anything that uh and uh once again as
a metaph formal system which is like a
formal system but it's a generalization
of the formal system that goes deeply
into the nature of life language and
what it takes to here's another way to
describe the
CT basically you've got a system you've
got this metal system and it relates
intelligence and
intelligibility reality has to be on
ontology and epistemology are coupled in
this thing so reality reality actually
has to recognize itself and process
itself it has to do both so that's
that's what it does it relates
intelligibility and intelligence which
are dual quantities in ctmu thusly
defining both of them in the recursive
sense it's a mutual recursive definition
of those two terms within this ctm
structure so uh and can even be regarded
as a theory of Consciousness for ex it
says what Consciousness is because the
way it
quantizes so is that enough yeah let's
start from what's most fundamental and
then how you work your way up from there
to derive your
theory okay
the theory is developed by a means
called logical induction you start with
uh you've heard of
uh thearts you know
kosum right
Kum which is I think therefore I am and
you heard of Berkeley's uh uh s pppi
okay which is basically to be is to be
perceived or to perceive right you start
with perception and cognition then you
develop the minimal model of how
cognition and perception work then you
induce an overall system that works by
those
processes okay and that's the way you
get to the ctmu it's called logical
induction been using that terminology
for years it's Superior to empirical
induction by the most scientists use
empirical induction which means that
they just kind of guesstimate
inductively guess what the proper theory
is and sort of AIX that you know sort of
glue it on to the observations that they
make that's how science usually works
this logical induction thing is a more
precise process more General
process let's get into some of the more
technical questions and for those who
are listening as a first pass you don't
have to understand all of the
terminology it's much better I think
wheeler said this or vigner not sure
which one he said that people are trying
to drink from the fire holes but the
point is to just get wet and then
another another quote that I like is
from noyman Von noyman who said you're
not supposed to understand math you get
used to it so that's in a similar vein
don't worry if you don't understand all
the terms or Follow The Logical steps in
the first pass of this podcast it's more
about re-watching and then
recontextualizing for me one of the
greatest Pleasures in life is being is
that feeling after you're so
confused and then all of a sudden you
start to glean what you're supposed to
and different connections are made and
you comprehend and you push through that
confusion okay so push through the
confusion eventually some parts of it at
least will make
sense is there a duality between syntax
and
semantics yes sorry is The Duality
between syntax and semantics a
generalization of stone
Duality well all these dualities are
related you know they're they're they're
all kinds of dualities out there you
know where Duality the the the idea of
Duality originally comes from right two
points determine a line two lines
determine a point where the lines
intersect you've got a point you know
whereas if you draw two points put two
points on a piece of paper you can draw
a line between that's a duality
basically you permute your uh your terms
uh and you still have an invariant truth
what the original form of the relation
remains true so that's that's what a
duality is anytime you can do that
anytime there is an invariant and you
can switch things around within that
invariant and the invariant stays true
that's a duality there are many kinds of
duality in the
CTV so how are syntax and semantics
related
well the syntax is intrinsic if you take
a look at a language that that are those
are the absolute invariant that every
every intelligible statement is made
them all right you know that grammar and
non-terminals and how non-terminals are
substituted cumulatively until they
result in terminal Expressions right
that's uh that's basically what it is if
human cognitive syntax is syntactically
covered by reality syntax how can one
meaningfully describe reality as
humans well as a language when you talk
about syntax and semantics you are
talking about a language and as I say
syntax is the intrinsic structure of the
language whereas sematics is that
involves things like definitions and
interpretations you have to Define terms
all the terms syntactic terms are
supposed to be primitive the
non-terminals are cognitively primitive
whereas when you get into semantics now
you're combining those Primitives to get
defined terms to get definitions then
you're combining those in certain ways
and then once you form your expression
now you have to interpret it or form a
model of it in some other structure that
you've got right and so it's a it's a
big process language is as I say the
most General algebraic structure there
is to see that any other algebraic
structure you can name is a language
when you write it down you are writing
it down in the form of language so
automattic ially you know language is
the most General algebra
exct right I heard you say that many
people think that mathematics is
extremely precise has High Fidelity it's
unequivocal whereas language natural
language is considered to be indistinct
opaque
dubious volutin at the edges so how
that's just that most people use it
sloppily that's all in reality it is not
there's nothing dubious about every math
mathematical language every mathematical
theory is by definition a
language so you have to decide how
precise you want to be how precisely you
want to formulate things and then you
make your judgment about you know what's
what's loosy and and what's tight is
there a relationship between the inere
expansive domain where syntactic
operators are entangled than mutually
absorbing and so this inner expansion
and love is there a relationship between
those two yes there is there's at least
an analogy between the two because when
when when things combine in the
non-terminal domain via inner expansion
when they overly each other that they
are more or less merging their
identities and that's what love is love
is also a combination of merger of
identities that enhances the
self-actualization or self-expression of
the combined entity in other words it's
synergistic it's more than the sum of
these
parts now of course you know that that
that
the merging the syntactic merging that
occurs due to Inner expansion that has
to be actualized and that actualization
is
semantical the first is a syntactic
process the second is a semantic process
and that's what causes what you as a
physicist would call Quantum wave
function
collapse or measurement events why is
there no such thing as a literal
interpretation is it because you
mentioned before we move between models
and to look at the symbols one must
apply an interpretation on it and so to
say literal interpretation is like
saying uninterpreted interpretation and
so it's
oxymoronic uh the meaning is very simple
and that is that if I hand you a book
written and say Sanskrit unless you
understand understand Sanskrit all
you're going to see is little geometric
shapes on the page and it is going to
have no meaning whatsoever to extract
any meaning whatsoever from those
symbols you first have to know the
alphabet the signature of the language
then you've got to know the the grammar
and the syntax of the language and then
you've got to actually put things
together you know put all the terms and
the Expressions together and then you've
got to interpret those or model those in
some framework that allows you to
actually make sense of them right all of
those steps are necessary these are
absolutely necessary steps of language
and as a matter of fact in the way we
deal with reality you can look at
reality external reality as a language
you're looking at it all of those steps
yeah they they all have to be solved for
they all have to be deciphered before
you can actually make sense of your
Environ